hi my name is reto Meier and I'm the
tech lead for Google's Android developer
relations team one of the most effective
ways you have at your disposal for
optimizing the efficiency of your data
transfers is eliminating user-driven
updates that means doing everything you
can to eliminate the refresh button
within your app most common reason
people hit refresh is because they don't
believe your app is displaying
up-to-date information if you're using
some form of client-side polling they're
probably right in fact every time you
create a repeating alarm to pin your
server to check for updates sundar kills
the bug droid stop the slaughter and use
Google Cloud messaging to have your
server notifying your app when there is
data ready to be downloaded or even
include the new data in the message
payload itself if you're using polling
you're forced to balance data freshness
with the resulting battery drain the
more often you pull for updates the
lower latency between the data changing
on the server and your up displaying
those updates but turning on the radio
to check for those updates also drains
the battery that's the worst of both
worlds when what you actually want is no
latency and as little battery drain as
possible Google Cloud messaging helps
you do this by offering a way to send
messages from your server to any
installed instance of your app as a
result you can stop polling which will
improve battery life and also improve
the freshness of your app once
configured you can transmit messages to
a specific ad in app installation or
multicast messages to multiple
recipients these messages can be simple
tickles notifying your app that there is
new data ready to download or it can
include the new data within the message
payload in this dev bite I focus on how
to use Google Cloud messaging to perform
more efficient data transfers the
details for setting up your GCM client
and server are in detailed
comprehensively in the documentation
that said it helps to understand the GCM
data flow it starts with your app on
each device registering itself by
sending a registry so message to the GCM
infrastructure in return it will be sent
a registration ID which we uniquely
identifies that instance of your app
running on that particular device you're
actually then send this identifier to
your server typically along with a
separate identifier that you can use to
identify a particular user or internal
your server now has a way to send
messages to a specific app or a specific
user via the Google Cloud messaging
infrastructure anything from breaking
news updated sports scores new email
messages or an updated list of news
articles this is enough to eliminate the
need for polling and ensures you never
turn on the radio to communicate with
the server that has nothing new to
download so your information in our
information architecture now needs to
determine the urgency of reflecting each
server change in your app you can set up
your server using either HTTP or CCS
using XMPP and encapsulate polar
payloads as JSON or plain text here
we're using JSON to create a message
starting with the registration IDs to
which we want to transmit our message by
default your Apple receive GCM messages
even if it's not running and the phone
is on standby you can help minimize
battery drain by setting delay while
idle to true indicating that your
message doesn't need to be sent
immediately if the device is on standby
instead these messages will be cured
until the device becomes active in fact
if you also set a collapse key only one
message will be sent when the device
does become active the collapse key is
any arbitrary string that the GCM
service can use to collapse a queue of
messages address to the same device so
in the device comes online or becomes
active it receives only one message
there's no guarantee that the message
the queue collapses to with the most
recent one you sent so these messages
are known as center sink and a best
suited to update tickles that tell you
app simply that there is new data ready
to up download you can go a step further
and set a time loop or for cute messages
expire using the time-to-live parameter
this determines how many seconds of GCM
servers should keep a message before
cancelling by default this is set to
four weeks but you can dramatically
reduce this for messages you know will
be out of date or replaced over a
shorter time period which is a
particularly useful feature for messages
with payload data included in the form
of an optional JSON object whose fields
represent key value pairs of data each
message can store up to 4k of data of
data which will be delivered as strings
within the intent bundle of receive GCM
messages as you can see here these non
collapsible or message with payload
messages are more than a sink t'kul
they're used when you need to deliver
every message because every message has
different content
notifications are a great example of how
you may use these payload messages by
including the current weather details
commentary and score after a touchdown
pass or breaking news headlines and
summaries within the payload of the GCM
message itself you're able to update
your users immediately with nominal
increment battery impact it is possible
to use these collapse keys with payload
messages but because the delivery order
isn't guaranteed and the collapse
message isn't guaranteed to be the last
one received you need to be careful not
to display outdated information if non
collapsible messages with payloads are
going to provide a specific improvement
to the user experience send to sync
messages are a better option as they put
less of a burden on the device battery
for example if your server notifies your
app every time there is a new article or
message it only needs to receive one
message telling it that it's time to
sync up which you can do using a sync
adapter to initiate the sink preferably
bundling a number of batch transfers
together as described in my dev bite on
batching bundling and using the sync
adapter using Google Cloud messaging
allows you to totally eliminate
client-side polling from your
applications in promote implemented
correctly you can configure the messages
transmitted to have as little impact on
the battery as possible using techniques
like short time to live parameters
collapse keys and the delay while idle
parameter to limit the number of
messages that you're actually
transmitted to your app by keeping your
apps constantly up-to-date you can
minimize latency and help eliminate the
refresh button used with sync adapters
and prefetching you can dramatically
improve the battery efficiency of your
apps